these grapes are ripe and
need to be picked but it's a risky
harvest this year
the situation in the north of the
israeli-occupied galan heights is tense
winemaker joao levy is worried about
more than his harvest
it's no longer safe here the fighting in
syria has reached us
rockets land here again and again
then everything is shut off but i do
trust our army to keep the situation
under control
of levi's vineyard is just a kilometer
from the syrian border
we hear repeated gunfire and see
exploded mortar shells
whether or not they were fired across
the border deliberately
the israeli army shoots back but
settlers like yo
of levi say this isn't enough
if we allow this to continue the
conflict will grow and get worse and
worse
the soldiers and extremists over there
should know that we will fight back
we have the ability we will
for israel the biggest problem at the
moment is not syria's assad regime
but the rise of islamist groups it's an
issue too for these israelis at kunitra
the only crossing between the
israeli-occupied golan heights and
syria they're debating whether it's
al-qaeda
is militants or the al-nusra front that
are on
israel's doorstep
it's all so close and really quite
frightening
you can almost see what's going on
without the need for binoculars
they're just walking around my gut
feeling is that things could explode at
any moment
it feels like the calm before the storm
there is growing concern that violence
could spill over from the civil war in
syria
especially after the attacks on the u.n
peacekeepers
right behind me in the buffer zone
between the occupied golan heights and
syria
not long ago fighters from the islamist
al-nusra front took control of the
syrian side of the kunitra crossing
and captured over 40 u.n peacekeepers
other units stationed there since the
mission began in 1974 fled to israel
the u.n has come under sharp criticism
because of this
this has been one of the quietest
borders of israel since
1974. the syrian side has fully
respected the ceasefire and so have we
and the peacekeeping forces actually did
not have much to do they were present
but they did not have much to do
now what can one infer from the fact
that those forces
fled uh once they started hearing
gunshots uh and actually we're not
fulfilling their mission
is those are complex lessons
people here say israel will need to
depend on itself for security
and keep a wary eye out for any
potential conflict
but observers say israel would not want
to see another front
open here in the north